hi everyone my name is john balbus and
it's a real pleasure to be with you here
today i want to start by thanking dr
regine dutard in the office of research
and women's health of nih for inviting
me to give this talk to you on women's
environment and health
i approach this talk with a lot of
gratitude but also
trepidation
as a white male trying to convey the
realities of people caught in harm's way
by virtue of their gender
as so many are also caught in harm's way
by virtue of the color of their skin so
i i hope that i'm able to convey both
the science and also these perspectives
to you with meaning
and without bias
here's the outline from my talk today
i'm going to focus the discussion on
three types of environmental exposures
endocrine disrupting chemicals
air pollution and climate change
but before i get into those i want to
start at the very beginning based on the
picture that you see there
i want to start with the creation of the
world in fact and honor the many
cultures whose creation stories
attribute our very existence to women
this is an image of sky woman falling
from the huron creation story that tells
of how sky woman fell through a rip in
the sky
and was caught before falling into the
watery surface of the planet by birds
skyward then created land on the back of
a turtle
according to that story the creation of
land required two things
it required the sacrifices of all of the
animals that she came to to see when she
landed
and it also came about
because of sky woman's dance that
brought the world into existence
and so our timeline begins with the
story of the first woman in harmony with
the planet and the environment
our timeline jumps
to about 110 years ago
1911 and it picks up the story of women
out of harm in harmony and in harm's way
in fact from their environment
i've chosen the triangle shirtwaist
factory fire
and this is a very um i'm an
occupational physician by training and
this was a very uh momentous
event in the history of occupational
health um short waists were the words
that were used for for women's blouses
at the time
i've chosen this factory fire because it
illustrates this duality it was a
tragedy of huge proportions the
culmination of years of horrific working
conditions in a garment factory the
exploitation of immigrant women
in this case mostly women from eastern
europe
and nearly 150 preventable deaths were
caused when a fire started and the women
were unable to escape because the owners
had locked the fire exits
and so it's an illustration of how
harmful exposures are often associated
with disadvantage and exploitation how
physical stressors are often associated
with psychosocial stressors
and then on the flip side it's also the
story of how women organizing to
challenge the status quo and joining
labor unions were ultimately able to
galvanize international women's day in
response to this
tragedy
in 1962 biologist rachel carson
published silent spring identifying ddt
and other persistent pesticides as
harmful chemicals
and hugely raising awareness of
environmental toxicity
in 1976 an explosion near cevaso italy
led to massive community exposure to the
chemical dioxin
awareness of the potential risks coming
from such an explosion led to a
similarly massive study
the scientists in that area were able to
collect a lot of blood samples and they
set up a cohort study that's now been in
operation for nearly 40 years
and this study is one of the key mark
studies to document
both the role of endocrine disrupting
chemicals in the health of women and
then the children that they bear
as well as the nature of
general inheritance of environmental
toxicity
the 1980s saw the expanded use of a
large number of chemicals with unique
properties of persistence and also the
ability to mimic endocrine hormones
these chemicals such as teflon and
gore-tex
found their way into nearly every
product in our homes from the coating of
our furniture to its stuffing to
the food
that the the food packaging we used and
even our cookware
in the same decade
researchers noting earlier in earlier
age at menarche and declining sperm
counts in men
started raising questions about whether
these persistent chemicals could be
starting to alter the endocrine and
reproductive systems in humans
in the 1990s
the new stories shifted from humans to
amphibians and reptiles as frogs and
alligators striking malformations like
the one in this picture
these malformations were ultimately
linked to endocrine disrupting chemicals
released into waterways in the ambient
environment
the 2000s saw an expansion in the
scientific activities around endocrine
disrupting chemicals and reproductive
health
researchers documented that adult
diseases could be associated with
environmental exposures early in life
and even exposures to previous
generations
this led to something called the dohad
hypothesis or the developmental origins
of health and disease which now informs
environmental awareness in the realms of
maternal child health and environmental
health more broadly
and the 2000s also saw the expansion of
the cdc's biomonitoring program looking
for hundreds of chemicals in the blood
of americans
and unfortunately finding them in men
women and children
very frequently in some cases
surprisingly frequently
and then lastly
i highlight the recognition of the
importance of gender for understanding
the impacts of and also combating the
effects of climate change and
environmental challenges more broadly
and i picked the date of 2014 this is
a hallmark date in the un framework
convention on climate change which
monitors the global response to climate
change
when it adopted something called the
lima work program on gender
which requires that all countries take a
gendered perspective and look at the
role of gender in in the impacts of
climate change and also the solution
space
so the story of endocrine disrupting
chemicals starts with diethyl
stilbestral or des
to which millions of women were exposed
prior to the mid-1960s in the united
states in europe and also in australia
while thalidomide awakened physicians
and scientists to the reality that
fetuses are not quote unquote perfect
parasites protected completely by the
placenta but instead are actually
vulnerable to chemical insults
you'll recall that thalidomide led to an
epidemic of birth defects in in women in
the children of women who would use that
it was the des catastrophe that unfolded
in the 1960s and 70s that brought
greater awareness to the phenomenon of
endocrine disruption and the
multi-generational impacts of in-utero
exposure to female children in
particular
beyond the sentinel finding of clear
cell vaginal adenocarcinoma
children of des treated mothers suffered
a wide range of other structural changes
and reproductive problems
and yet despite this awareness des was
still given to livestock as a feed
additive until 1979.
you'll remember at the timeline i showed
mentioned biomonitoring
and here's just one graph demonstrating
how widespread exposures were
this graph is from 2004 and in this case
it's showing a population of pregnant
women
i mentioned some of these surpri some of
these findings were kind of surprising
and this would be one of them
the chemicals that are represented by
those blue orange green and purple bars
all have endocrine disrupting
potential they're chemicals like
organochlorine pesticides brominated
flame retardants polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons and phthalates and
alkyl perfluorinated alkyl substances or
phos
and you can see
even the least exposed woman
represented by that bar at the far left
of this graph
has well over
25 of these chemicals in her body
and even the most exposed woman in you
know
in in this set uh doesn't have that many
more so so the exposures to these
chemicals were common multiple and
pretty universal
most endocrine disrupting chemicals have
chemical structures that are very
similar to the body's own hormones and
this slide shows the many different
mechanisms by which they can disrupt
normal function
by mimicking sex hormones these
chemicals can either stimulate or block
hormone receptors
change a cell's signaling mechanisms
which leads to downstream kind of
effects
and in some cases even cause changes to
the expression of dna
through something called epigenetic
alterations and epigenetic alterations
are things like the methylation of the
dna molecule which affects its
expression and also changes to the
histone structures and the histones are
proteins that help to coil up or unravel
the dna and help to control its
expression as well
these epigenetic mechanisms can actually
these changes to to the methylation or
the histones can be inherited and
they're one of the ways that these
exposures can propagate health effects
across multiple generations
and this illustration illustrates this
the kind of transgenerational effects in
a more visual way
because the immature oocytes in a female
fetus which you can see there on that
right
picture
because those oocytes will ultimately
become the mature oocytes
when that fetus is born and becomes a
woman of reproductive age and then
ultimately
become that woman's child
any direct effects on those oocytes by
chemicals
that occur in utero
can manifest in the grandchild of the
exposed pregnant woman
and so the the grandmother to grandchild
effect can be a direct effect of
chemicals on the cells
within that fetus
in order to reach the great grandchild
or what's labeled as the f3 generation
there has to be some kind of heritable
change
such as the kind of changes i was just
mentioned and that are being
increasingly understood
through studying the epigenetic
alterations i just mentioned
most of the effects of des that we've
been talking about were observed through
the f2 generation or through the
grandchild
but as the f3 generation
is born grows and matures further study
may find more effects being inherited in
this fashion
and this table illustrates
the the multiplicity of effects of
endocrine disrupting chemicals and the
fact that different chemicals can cause
slightly different responses from
endocrine systems or in some cases
contrary responses making predictions of
how mixtures and cumulative exposures
will affect women and children very
complicated
so for example low molecular weight
phthalates the low
mwp on this table can lead to earlier
growth spurts while high molecular
weight phthalates have been shown to
delay growth
this complexity and mixture of effects
especially combined with the multiple
exposures that we've shown makes it
difficult to detect a signal
to detect population level changes in in
reproductive health or other kinds of
health impacts
but understanding
that on an individual basis
these chemicals can have potentially
serious consequences for reproductive
and overall health is leading to efforts
to reduce exposures to all endocrine
disruptors through a variety of
regulatory mechanisms
i'd like to move on now to considering
air pollution in women's health
while we've known for many years that
air pollution causes exacerbation of
lung diseases like asthma and copd
can cause heart disease and heart
attacks and premature death for both
sexes
more recent research has highlighted the
impacts of prenatal exposure to air
pollution on the developing brain and
other organs as well as documenting
adverse neurological impacts on women
towards the end of life
and this illustration shows some of the
mechanisms by which air pollution
affects the brain as well as some of its
other effects
um this includes uh and on the right
there you can see there's a number one
that that shows direct transport of
oxidizing air pollutants that may
deposit in the nasal passages and get
transported directly to the brain via
the olfactory nerves
the second is
the stimulation of inflammation cascades
and transport of inflammatory cytokines
from the lungs where those particles can
deposit
through this through the blood
circulation to the to harm the blood
vessels but also get into the brain by
that mechanism
and then the third mechanism that's
shown here is alterations of the gut
microbiome
recent
research is showing that air pollution
can alter the gut microbiome and we're
learning more and more how the gut
microbiome interacts with the brain and
can cause changes in in brain function
and structure as well
and then you can see in the effects
there that that find particulate matter
or pm 2.5
has also recently been shown to directly
affect women's fecundity lowering
ovarian reserve and new studies
so a wide range of health effects
for men women and children but some of
them unique to women's situation
and there's another aspect that's unique
to women's situation
which is uh the fact that
that
women are
predominantly exposed to household air
pollution
this is a problem of global scale and
it's related to the indoor combustion of
biofuels floating in heating among the
world's poorest populations
because most cultures place women in the
roles of caretaker
fuel gatherer and chief cook women and
their children are the most exposed to
household air pollution
leading to an enormous toll of lung
diseases and infections
heart and brain diseases and premature
death and you can see the quote there
from dr flavio bustrello who was the
assistant director general of the who
confirming that for women in low and
middle income countries household air
pollution is the single leading
environmental health risk
and so as we consider both endocrine
disrupting chemicals and air pollution
and the effects throughout different
lights life stages
the need to capture
as well as we possibly can
the totality of these exposures all of
these exposures throughout the life
course for research purposes starts to
become clear
a scientist named christopher wilde
coined the term expose zone 15 to 20
years ago to convey the same
comprehensive approach to understand
environmental exposures that researchers
were using when they talked about the
genome that ome genome to convey the
sense of the entire structure of our dna
this diagram just shows how measurements
of maternal and placental chemicals can
be used to capture the exposome of the
developing child
but the exposure very importantly is
more than just chemicals and air
pollutants
while i don't have time to go into all
of these exposures we know that many
other environmental factors from aspects
of our built environments like
walkability and green space
to lifestyles and behaviors to the
social and political environment that
leads to stress and constrained mobility
all of these can have enormous impacts
on our health both physical and mental
and importantly this slide also shows
that other aspects of our environment
including extreme weather events and
prolonged climate abnormalities
associated with climate change also have
profound effects on the health of all of
us
this slide about the impacts of climate
change on human health illustrates the
many different pathways and consequent
health outcomes by which climate change
affects our health and well-being
for each of these pathways women may
have unique exposures susceptibilities
and risks
i'll go into into a bit more detail on
just two of these pathways in a moment
first i just want to highlight the fact
that we
when we try to understand the impacts of
climate change on especially from a
gendered perspective we must take into
account contexts
of these climate change exposures
these include things like co-exposures
to air pollution and other chemicals
includes the constraints on men and
women by poverty often putting the
poverty lack of education discrimination
and other socio-economic factors which
may lead to disproportionate exposures
to a wide variety of environmental risks
and then a broader context of governance
land use
and urban or rural infrastructure among
other factors
all of these contexts
influence whether or not an individual
gets exposed whether or not they have a
harmful health effect from being exposed
and whether or not they're able to act
care or otherwise
be able to to be resilient to those
risks
and so this table which is adapted from
a paper written with colleagues from the
university of colorado in the united
kingdom
illustrates some of these factors in a
women's health perspective
women may experience unique or
disproportionate health risks from
extreme heat or climate related
disasters for several reasons
some reasons have to do with biological
factors that heighten risk
like a higher working metabolic rate or
reduced ability to sweat and cool makes
women in some cases more
susceptible to adverse consequences of
heat exposure
but other reasons have to do with
political or cultural factors and
discrimination
recognition of the importance of these
factors for women's health is a part of
the drive by the global organizations
combating climate change and its effects
force this gendered perspective and to
address the impacts on women subtly and
comprehensively
for example hiv aids is not generally
thought of as being a climate sensitive
disease and yet entered perspective
illustrates the connections between
climate change
drought
population displacement and the
vulnerability of young women hiv
as the story about this this study
that was published in post-medicine
demonstrates
and so having focused most of my talk
about the unique risks women face to
their health from environmental
exposures
i'd like to be returning to the start
and to honoring women's contributions to
bringing human society into greater
harmony with our planet environment
and i start with this quote from bandana
shiva a leading thinker in the role of
women in sustainability and
you can see she says that we're either
going to have a future where uh women
lead the way to make peace with the
earth
we're not going to have a human future
at all
next i want to recognize the continued
role of women organizing as they did
after the triangle short waste fire
to affect change
and this includes
groups in the united states like the
mom's clean air force and silent spring
institute which
in case of the clean air force obviously
deals with air pollution the silent
spring institute focuses its work on the
endocrine disrupting chemicals
as well as global groups like the
women's environment women's earth
alliance and the women's environment and
development organization
and i want to also
recognize some of the great individual
women leaders in environmental health
issues
that's rachel carson who published
silence spring next to her is christiana
fageres who was the the lead of the
un framework
convention on climate change helping to
address
the impacts of climate change and reduce
them
in the middle east group who wrote one
of the first
sentinel reports on sustainability with
her commission
and who later became the head of the
world health organization and worked on
women's health issues
next to her is gina mccarthy who was a
leading advocate for health as the
administrator of the environmental
protection agency and then to the right
is the next generation greta thunberg
who is clearly a woman
providing leadership in the
environmental arena
finally i want to acknowledge the
enormous importance of women's
empowerment more broadly in solving the
climate crisis
project drawdown which analyzed the top
100 measures to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
has concluded that two aspects of women
in women's empowerment family planning
and educating girls
if you combine them they become the
single greatest step that can be taken
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
and so we come full circle
as a woman's dance created a livable
world for humans
the uplifting of women around the world
is essential
to the survival of humans on the planet
i hope this talk has raised your
awareness and spurred many new thoughts
on the connections between our
environment and women's health
and i thank you for your attention
you